hi I'm Crispin start well I teach
philosophy at Dickinson College in
Carlisle PA and I'm the author of
against the state an introduction to
anarchist political theory the focus of
the book is the destruction of all the
traditional arguments in favor of the
moral legitimacy of state power I think
there is no moral justification for
state power whatsoever and that would
entail that it's not the case that the
state ought to exist so that's the
thrust of the argument I mean it's
rather a philosophical than a practical
approach to these questions I suppose so
I'm not really saying here's a vision of
our anarchist future I'm saying here's
what's wrong with the justifications of
state power here's why state power
cannot be justified
I mean the most traditional arguments in
favor of state power probably social
contract theories connected with figures
like Hobbes Locke Rousseau and also
connected with the American Constitution
which is actually formulated as a
contract and the basic thrust of that
argument is that we are subject to state
power in virtue of our agreement to be
subject to that power but this is a
ridiculously bad argument I mean for one
thing because I cannot withdraw my
agreement so I mean I I don't I do not
consent to be ruled by the state of
Pennsylvania or the United States
government but I'm not in a position
where I can withdraw or where I can be
immune from that power and virtue of
failing to consent and so consent isn't
in question at all I mean I face
overwhelming force and you know so the
legitimacy of the state does not rest on
the consent of the governed if it did
there would be no legitimate States
well I probably an anarchist since I was
12 or 11
growing up in DC will turn you into an
anarchist or it might I'm expecting the
revolution to emerge from Wheaton you
know high schoolers in the in the DC
area who are sort of embroiled in the
bureaucracy of the American state I
my parents were Marxists and I was sort
of a baby Marxist for a little while and
then I read you know Emma Goldman the
figures like that when I was quite young
and I realized that you know Marxism is
a totalitarian philosophy in my view and
you know my basic idea was that freedom
is the most valuable political goal and
that if if that's the case then I
couldn't be a Marxist
it's certainly outside the spectrum of
contemporary American politics left and
right because I think both the left and
the right are enthusiasts for state
power I mean I think you can see this
just in the you know the George Bush
budgets or something like that you know
I mean there used to be quite an active
libertarian wing of fairly mainstream
right-wing politics republicanism that
you know that is seems to be long gone
and what we have on left and the right
is status solutions to any given problem
some mystic about it seems to me that
for hundreds of years essentially the
power of the state has increased
steadily you know with little glitches
here and there and it strikes me as very
likely that that will continue to be the
case for the foreseeable future and I
don't see any kind of social movement
that can effectively put a halt to that
so I expect you know that as I say in
the book my my children's children will
be even more thoroughly flypaper to the
state than I am all the Wars of the 20th
century all the genocides of the 20th
century state power is a necessary
condition for those Ward's wars and
genocides and I think that as state
power increases the power of states to
accomplish you know massive slaughter
increases steadily and so that I feel
like the state is likely to be the end
of the human species so that's not too
optimistic I suppose